the first public appearance by new york
democratic governor andrew cuomo
since the bombshell revelations of
sexual harassment allegations
from the state attorney general and that
report from the a.g
meanwhile democratic state lawmakers are
deserting cuomo by the dozens as
impeachment talk
intensifies and the first of his alleged
victims to come forward
is taking the governor to court
correspondent brian yennis has tonight's
story from new york
today new york governor andrew cuomo was
spotted lounging poolside next to a
woman typing on a laptop
at the governor's mansion in albany
there is no sign he's resigning despite
pressure from democrats
just get the hell out of the way i mean
in the end maybe he could
close off his career with one act of
dignity and decency and just step aside
but don't bet on that according to the
new york post cuomo was bunkered up
wednesday inside the governor's mansion
locked up with his closest advisors
strategizing his next move
perhaps a press conference different
from tuesday's taped response
to respond to the damning investigation
which found he sexually harassed 11
employees
one of cuomo's staunches allies and
friends new york's democratic party
chair jay jacobs says
he was honest with the governor i was
very direct with the governor as to
where
support was and that he didn't have
the support anywhere that he needed it i
was very clear about that
according to the latest fox news count
there is enough support
in the state assembly and senate to
impeach and convict cuomo
in a letter to cuomo's lawyers today the
new york state assembly's judiciary
committee chair wrote quote
the committee's investigation is nearing
completion and the assembly will soon
consider potential articles of
impeachment
against your client i want
accountability not just
for the victims of the sexual harassment
but i want accountability for the 15
000 victims that died in the nursing
homes
the deadline for cuomo's lawyers to
submit defense evidence
is next friday the 13th meanwhile cuomo
accuser lindsey boylan is filing the
first civil lawsuit against the governor
for retaliation
her attorney releasing a statement
saying in part it was a calculated
effort
by the governor and his team to send a
message to ms boylan
and every other survivor to be quiet or
face the consequences
tonight cuomo's office says they will
cooperate with the assembly's
impeachment investigation and that the
governor
appreciates the opportunity to present
his perspective
brett brian yenis in new york brian
thank you